permettre à des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi de se réinsérer dans la société
grâce à la transformation alimentaire de
fruits et légumes invendus c'est
l'ambition de l'association bon et
rebond à Rambouillet cet après-midi
Xavier bénévole au sein de l'association
égyptie en insertion sont en pleine
conception d'une nouvelle recette pomme
caramel le nom en fait de vent sera vive
la récré
le test d'âme il a été fait 100 pectine
et là on se rend compte en fait que
c'est que c'est vraiment trop liquide
donc du coup j'ai ajusté mais j'ai mis
j'ai mis à vue de nez comme ça c'est
d'expérience j'ai mis
0,4%, ça fait 63 g de pectine au travers
de la cuisine c'est un véritable moment
de partage que permet l'association et
un moyen de se réinsérer dans la vie
professionnelle tu pourras faire goûter
à tes enfants
au début je vous promets c'était un peu
compliqué mais voilà j'ai repris le
rythme c'est bon là je suis très bien
tout le monde s'entend bien tout le
monde oui oui il y a pas de souci aucun
problème après la préparation place à la
mise en pot par Gypsy et Nabil également
en insertion comme toujours au sein de
l'association le travail se fait en
équipe donc là on est contrôle c'est
bien fermé à l'origine de ce projet
pierre rouge le directeur de
l'association qui au travers d'une
activité anti-gaspillage a réussi à
allier la formation à la réinsertion les
personnes en insertion sont donc des
personnes très éloignées de l'emploi ou
institution handicap sont des gens qu'on
embauche 28 heures par semaine et qui
donc reprennent un peu contact avec le
travail donc arrivé à un horaire précis
avoir des collègues de travail avoir un
chef qui va vous donner des consignes
des ordres qu'il faut entendre et une
progression régulière de l'apprentissage
qui est à
expérimenté un apprentissage appuyé par
les bénévoles de l'association qui
jouent un rôle de relais c'est le cas de
Xavier bénévole et trésorier qui s'est
lancé dans l'aventure bon et rebond des
sacréation tout est dans le dans le nom
de l'association c'est bon ce qu'on fait
pendant souvent assez fier en fait de ce
qu'on sort en fait comme comme produit
de nos ateliers et puis le rebond c'est
l'essence du du projet une entreprise
sociale solidaire et familiale qui porte
déjà ses fruits chaque jour ce sont près
de 150 pots qui sont créés par les
personnes en insertion et par les
bénévoles depuis septembre 2021 ce sont
21000 pots qui ont été vendus